have you observed yourself
working through skepticism
cynicism and optimism about the power of
neural networks what is that trajectory
been like for you it looks like neural
networks before 2006 forming part of an
indistinguishable to me
other people might have had better
Distinction on it indistinguishable blob
of different AI methodologies all of
which are promising to achieve
intelligence without us having to know
how intelligence works
you have the people who said that if you
just like manually program lots and lots
of knowledge into the system line by
line at some point all the knowledge
will start interacting it will know
enough and it will wake up
um you've got people saying that if you
just use evolutionary computation if you
try to like mutate lots and lots of
organisms that are competing together
that's that's the same way that human
intelligence was produced in nature so
we'll do this and it will wake up
without having the idea of how AI works
and you've got people saying well we
will study neuroscience and we will like
learn the out we'll learn the algorithms
off the neurons and we will like imitate
them without understanding those
algorithms which was a part I was pretty
skeptical it's because like hard to
reproduce re-engineer these things
without understanding what they do
um and like and and so we will get AI
without understanding how it works and
there were people saying like well we
will have giant neural networks and we
will Train by gradient descent and when
they are as large as the human brain
they will wake up uh we will have
intelligence without understanding how
intelligence works and from my
perspective this is all like an
indistinguishable lab of people who are
trying to not get to grips with the
difficult problems understanding how
intelligence actually works
that said
I was never skeptical that evolutionary
computation
would not work in the limit like you
throw enough computing power at it it
obviously works
that is where humans come from
um and it turned out that you can throw
less computing power than that at
gradient descent
if you are doing some other things
correctly
and you will get intelligence without
having any idea of how it works and what
is going on inside
um it wasn't ruled out by my model that
this could happen I wasn't expecting it
to happen I wouldn't have been able to
call neural networks rather than any of
the other paradigms for getting like
massive amount like intelligence without
understanding it
and I wouldn't have said that this was a
particularly smart thing for a species
to do which is an opinion that has
changed less than my opinion about
whether you or not you can actually do
it